this is a production of Cornell
University it is interesting uh that
what I'm specifically going to talk to
you about is uh something I have been
thinking about for those 38 odd years
and we we should have got around to
measuring some of these things a lot
earlier but uh better late than never um
the the Gates Foundation invests in
agricultural research and plan breing in
particular because um the there's a
pretty strong relationship between the
the productivity of small holder farmers
and uh their uh livelihood uh their
income their well-being and their
resilience so our um and our our theory
of change is that um you know uh farmers
can have access to adopt and and uh uh
produce with um varieties that are
higher yielding get a steady stream of
of improved varieties that are are
developed quickly in the face of a
rapidly changing climate and market
conditions that their their productivity
will increase and this will this will
translate into into higher income so
that's that's why we've been investing
heavily in in crop Improvement for a
number of years um plant breeding needs
to change quickly in the face of of uh
changing climate there are a number of
of circumstances that are uh really
affecting
um plant breeding systems in in in the
developing world climate change you know
is adaptation is is is uh something we
need to be paying more attention to um
oh I was yeah sorry market linkage um
and the complexity of markets being
served by uh uh small holder farmers in
Africa and South Asia which is where the
Gates Foundation uh invests most of its
effort uh are are is is increasing so
most African farmers are
consuming some of what they produce but
they're marketing a lot they're really
riant on Crop Production for cash um the
capacity of national agricultural
research and extension systems is
increasing uh in in South Asia and
subsaharan Africa so old models that
rely on on external research
organizations like um The Gates found uh
the uh
CG developing and delivering uh finish
varieties that farmers are going to
adopt are are are less and less relevant
and um are uh not ideal for uh uh
dealing with complex uh environments uh
complex markets large numbers of
Commodities genotyping costs have
dropped enabling us to uh apply uh
genomic selection genomic prediction
methods that require require mid density
genotyping to uh to generate the uh
genomic relationship M Matrix but
they're not dropping much anymore it
seems like on a per sample basis I think
we're at a point where we can assume
that those costs are going to be um
uh reasonably stable for a few years um
but information phenotyping Technologies
are improving rapidly and this should be
translating into a real revolution in
the way that pip breeding pipelines are
designed uh and implemented
um so far it's not uh I and I I firmly
believe that the the technology that
really is um transformational for plant
breeding it's
not uh uh Digital Imaging it's not
um uh
uh
um artificial intelligence it's really
the the genomic relationship matrix it's
the uh ability to to uh link information
from from relatives and and use that in
uh in pipeline design the the genomic
relationship Matrix allows information
from close relatives to replace
replication at stage one and this is
potentially transformational in the way
that breeding pipelines are designed
most information contributing to the
accuracy of predictions genomic
predictions come from close relatives
from full and half sibs there's some you
know some information as as uh uh
training databases expand uh and and
deepen
some information from more distant
relatives if the population's pretty
tightly closed but uh um and and this I
think this concept of replacing reps
with relatives is an important one that
we need to codify uh and turn into uh
rules of thumb uh that are going to help
plant breeders think about how to R
design the pipeline my guesstimate is
that uh you know for inbred relatives a
um uh two full sibs four half sibs are
are equivalent to one
replication uh and uh I don't know if if
that is true or not so I hope somebody
with the skills to test that uh with a
simulation or a model will will do that
so we uh we we do need that rule of
thumb um replacing reps with relatives
allows us to implement sparse testing
which is a uh you know really the
transformational technology which drives
uh uh makes makes possible few things
and I'm sure you're you're you're most
of you are familiar with what what we
mean by sparse testing but sparse
testing strategies uh for uh breeding
value
estimation uh treat the hati rather than
the lineer the Clone as the selection
candidate contrasting Hypes that are
segregating uh in a family are dispersed
across different different backgrounds
different lines or clones uh and they're
also then those lines or clones and the
Hypes can be dispersed across many
environments and so the um uh th this
allows uh uh you to estimate without
blowing up seed without doing a big you
know seed increase estimate the effect
of uh a um uh of a haet type uh across
backgrounds across lines and then
rebuild that you know knit those
together additively into a prediction of
breeding value um
so this this gives us the ability to do
three things that I'll focus on uh today
uh one is to shorten the breeding cycle
and and that that is done in two ways
one is uh uh eliminate that seed
increase step or a couple of seed
increase steps before you can do any
multilocation testing and uh another is
uh to allow multiple location testing at
early stages with with relatives
replacing replicates and that that
allows you to to select parents out of
out of early stages um it uh sparse
testing allows us to increase selection
accuracy by better sampling the target
population of environments and the the
the breeding I should have added the
breeding population itself because you
can increase the size of the breeding
population and evaluate more lines in a
family rather than more replicates of
the single line uh and it's going to
allow us there there's this an issue
that's specific to subsaharan Africa
which a region that has not gone through
to the same extent an agricultural
transformation and intensification of of
of production that has occurred in other
regions post Green
Revolution uh the and moving in these
areas the
uh um the difference in management
between the research station of the farm
can be very great and we may see a lot
as a result of that a lack of
correlation between performance on the
research station and on the farm and
um because of this model training for
genomic prediction on the research
station may not be very accurate so we
we may need to move uh our model
training on farm and sparse testing
allows us to do that um how does it
shorten the breeding cycle just just
quickly to run through this you know a
conventional pipeline will will um uh
generate lines uh via pedigree or Single
Seed descent in uh uh or you know clonal
propagation in two or three years um
will then conduct one year of final uh
seed increase Nursery observation we'll
generally conduct an initial agronomic
evaluation which most programs refer to
as stage one uh takes a year very often
at very few locations uh one two three
locations and then uh a small small
fraction I haven't portrayed that very a
small fraction of those lines that are
in the in the in the breeding nursery
and in the uh stage one will be Advanced
into multilocation testing that really
samples the target population of
environments and this cycle typically
takes six or seven years in a reasonably
well uh well-managed program um the one
of the initial ways that the genomic
relationship Matrix has been applied and
even simply uh tighter pipeline manag
M to shorten the cycle has been to uh uh
take parents out of stage one and
recycle them not to continue to test
them most selection intensity is applied
in stage one you know most uh programs
will will cut we use stage one as a uh
as a culling step and uh eliminate 80
90% of the material then uh and on the
basis of of performance at one two three
locations and then they'll conduct
multilocation testing with a as I
mentioned with a a small fraction of
material but but simply uh trying to
increase accuracy at stage one by
increasing multilocation testing a bit
uh using the genomic relationship Matrix
uh improves the selection of parents
allows you to cut some years off testing
before you identify a parent to go back
into the crossing block cutting the
cycle length down to two or three years
or three or four years
um really implementing sparse testing
Distributing selection candidates at an
early stage across many
environments uh will allow further
reduction in the in the length of the
cycle it may allow us and this is a a a
a a question i' I'd throw out to to you
who are starting uh uh research careers
um it may allow us to to combine the
initial agronomic testing step and and
the uh the final visual Nursery
evaluation step which is almost still
universally used still takes up a year
in the cycle uh cutting a year out of
the cycle if your cycle is four years
cutting your cycle to three years has a
big impact on potential genetic gain so
if we can take those uh replace those
replicates with full sibs if the if the
cost of of genotyping comes down a
little bit uh and um uh allows us to uh
genotype much you know a larger fraction
of the of the initial population at
stage one uh we may be able to uh uh you
know do that final final call and uh
evaluate breeding value in the same step
and get get uh Cycles down to two or
three years without going to uh um
breeding systems that completely
dellink uh uh phenotyping from uh of of
selection candidates from the from the
recom the selection and recombination
cycle um one question we run into often
from from people when we suggest that
that uh we should be testing stage one
material at many more locations is how
are we going to afford to run all those
locations is stage one and I ask well
how many locations are you testing your
stage three or stage four material at
and they'll often say oh 10 12 you know
locations many locations that's the
answer use the same locations package up
your early stage material uh which is
easy to do with a a sparse testing
design and distribute that material at
those
locations
um the you know applying the genomic
relationship Matrix replacing uh reps
with
relatives uh allows us also to improve
uh sampling of the tpe in a conventional
breeding population you know you might
have uh this is just another way of
presenting what I what I just did you
might have um
20,000 fixed lines or or clones at the
end of your uh your uh line development
process in in any given cohort if it's a
big program um tested at one evaluated
at one location screened at one location
and then you might Advance 300 of those
into your initial agronomic trial what
people call stage one maybe 300
replicated uh twice at each of uh two
locations so 1,200 plots devoted to 300
selection candidates and you've you've
reduced your population maybe uh uh
um uh between these two steps uh
massively you know from from stage one
into multilocation testing you might
take 50 candidates and replicate them
across I think I've got eight
environments here represented by my
green blobs and uh uh with with
replicated trials uh 50 entries three
reps at each location might be a typical
uh design uh 1,00 plots again um but
you've only in this scheme you've
devoted you you've you're devoting most
of your multilocation testing capacity
for agronomic traits to a very small
number of genotypes 50 genotypes out of
the initial say 20
pounds um this is uh how the Eerie
reading program book when I got there
the uh uh that program was generating
something like 100,000 new fixed lines a
year uh something like 30 of them got
off the the main research station at Los
BOS if I if I remember correctly Susan
um sparse testing allows us to at stage
one uh move um many more selection
candidates out to different location
those would be 150 different entries at
each of those locations linked by the
genomic relationship Matrix so they you
know they uh all of the information on
those on those families uh can can uh be
incorporated into the genomic
prediction so that that gives a much
better sampling of the selection
environment of of the the tpe and
um you know one way to conceptualize the
change that's required is is to uh think
about where are we putting our testing
resources and where are we applying our
our selection pressure in a conventional
pipeline we're applying our selection
pressure in very few environments to
very large population calling very hard
with very little information the idea is
as cheaply as possible to winnow the
population down in a uh uh J when when
the objective of stage one is to train a
genomic selection model you want to put
much more of your testing resources into
that initial stage you want to evaluate
materials in multiple location trials at
initial
stages
um this brings us to the the uh the
third I would say
transformational uh potential
application of uh sparse testing and for
genomic prediction and that's dealing
with the lack of correlation between the
farm and the research station
particularly in in regions that haven't
undergone agricultural intensification
which uh characterizes subsaharan Africa
still um I
uh it's the the progress in increasing
fertilizer use uh on a
uh mineral fertilizer use on a on a
percor basis in Subhan Africa is
extremely slow average inorganic
fertilizer application rates on cropland
in subsaharan Africa are still around 20
kilos per hecton that has barely budged
in the time that I've been working for
the Gates Foundation in sort of tracking
this over the last few years fertilizer
application rates in South uh Asia are
five six times that level on average in
uh
China uh uh and uh Europe North America
10 to 15 to 20 times and that's not
changing and that is the reason for the
yield gap between Africa
and uh the rest of the world it's not
plant breeding um but the uh we are
breeding for those environments right so
we have to breed for the environments
that exist
um relative to research stations farmers
in subsaharian Africa use much less
fertilizer produce under lower plant
densities have less effective weed
control often
intercrop um and the differences in
management between uh you know this type
of of maze environment this type of rice
environment uh versus this uh uh high
input maze field in in Kenya um are may
lead to to low uh low
correlation uh low genetic correlation
uh in in evaluation of germ plasm um
sparse testing can be adapted to deal
with this problem we can uh we should be
considering including a new trait on
Farm performance in model training uh in
an index with performance uh with other
screens I'm not suggesting that we
should replace
all testing on the research station with
testing on Farm but we do need to uh in
in um systems like this we need to be uh
devoting considerable resources to uh
training our phenotyping for model
training on
farms so the the you know the the the
conceptual framework for thinking about
whether testing on Farm will produce
more genetic gain than testing on the
station is um is the correlated response
model where we we uh we consider yield
under farmer management and and yield on
the research station as correlated uh
characteristics um the yield on the the
station is meant to predict uh in an
indirect selection framework uh
performance on Farm
um and so uh in order to to uh uh assess
how well we can predict uh breeding
value for yield on farms based on yield
on station we need to use uh old uh uh
uh indirect selection framing uh
originally uh uh formalized by uh by by
Falconer um uh I applied this to the
problem of of as as Jean luk was
mentioning the problem of selecting for
for stress Pro and environments uh in
oats um for my PhD work and and uh
extended it to uh look at um
participatory varietal selection models
uh in in the paper cited there um but uh
and I I didn't uh work in oats because I
was uh concerned about selecting oats
for low productivity environment it's
because you could do massive experiments
in Fry's lab with oats and generate a
lot of a lot of
locations with with Hill plots so that
that's why we work to not but the um you
know correlated response on Farm to
selection on the research station is a
function of selection intensity uh the
um uh accuracy of selection on the
research station the genetic correlation
between the research station in farm and
the uh uh additive genetic variance on
Farm uh and this can be uh compared to
um a uh
direct a prediction of direct response
to selection on Farm which is just a
function of accuracy of of on Farm
selection and uh the additive genetic uh
standard deviation on Farm um and this
allows us to you know set up this uh
this relationship where um uh the um you
know we would expect
um uh correlated response uh on Farm to
selection on the research station to be
higher than direct selection on Farm if
the genetic correlation is relatively
low and the accuracy of selection on the
station is much higher than selection on
farm and you know that's not an
unreasonable assumption we we hope that
our our experiments uh uh sorry if the
accuracy is relatively High I meant the
genetic correlation is relatively High
we we hope that our experiments on the
research station are are in some way
predictive of performance on farm and we
hope that you know we're doing work on
the research station because we can get
more accurate results there is that
really the case
um if accuracy on farm and on station
are similar in the genetic correlation
uh between performance on farm and on
station is 0 five well it's kind of
trivial that uh you would expect um
doing on uh you know training your your
uh your model on on Farm as opposed to
on the research ation would allow you to
significantly or substantially increase
the the rate of genetic
gain um so we we um the foundation has
begun supporting pilot experiments where
we train uh in we we're working with the
breeding program Bean breeding program
at seat and Maze breeding programs at
simmit in uh eastern and southern Africa
to uh uh train uh GS models at state
stage one uh on farms um using a a farm
as incomplete block design where we we
assign uh a small number of of uh
selection candidates to each Farm
randomizing those candidates from
different families uh uh from the same
family across many farms in the tpe
these experiments have to be be pretty
large obviously if you're training a
model you need a relatively large
population uh there's no point in trying
to train a genomic selection model with
50 candidates uh so we need uh
relatively large populations which is
one of the reasons we don't want to
replicate selection units we want to
devote our resources to generating a lot
of lines a lot of clones from each cross
lots of full sibs getting them out into
these trials um the the environments
where this is uh of Interest tend to be
very variable uh um physically
agronomically and in terms of the uh uh
uh the population of farmers who who's
working in that environment there are
farmers uh in in uh in these uh uh in
these areas that are um uh much richer
much poorer able to apply fertilizer not
able to apply fertilizer they need to be
generally speaking they need to be able
to use the same
varieties uh so we need to be able to to
uh to s sample that variability both
both uh um uh biological and uh and
social and economic socioeconomic
variability uh in the design um we we we
need uh uh careful sampling of farm and
farmer
heterogeneity
um initial efforts to do on Farm testing
at different stages have tended to put a
fairly large number of entries on Farm
often 10 15 20 entries on a single farm
that tends to use up a lot of land uh it
requires uh um the people who are
implementing the farm to work with
larger Farmers so that they're they're
if you uh try to test a lot of entries
on a single Farm you tend to bias the
experiment uh in favor of larger Farmers
farmers who are better uh connected to
the market farmers who are applying more
inputs so so uh to ensure that small
farmers poor Farmers female Farmers uh
uh disadvantaged farmers are properly
sampled we tend to use uh we're in in
these experiments we're using small farm
as incomplete block sizes three to five
uh selection candidates per far uh so
we're moving from a sparse from from
this type of testing on the research
station and the the evidence is that 8
10 15 locations per year is probably
enough uh geographically climatically to
sample a Target population of
environments it's not enough uh in in uh
um to uh uh sample the the uh properly
sample the population of farmers in uh
in in most Subs African system so we
moved to a system where we in instead of
dividing selection you know 1,00
selection candidates among eight Farms
150 candidates per Farm we might move
we're to system where we take our our
1,00 entries divide them up among 300
Farms four candidates per Farm uh and
this allows us to uh you know the
question here is uh are we do we have
enough linkage from the genomic
relationship Matrix among those Farms to
to generate accuracy uh I'll cut to the
Chase and say generally it looks like we
do uh we this gives us the opportunity
to to uh substratified
the farmer population as well so we
can um disaggregate that population we
can look at farmers who are applying
fertilizer and not applying fertilizer
we can look at uh plots that are uh
primarily managed by men versus plots
that are primarily managed by women uh
and uh look at the uh the genetic
correlation between those plots look at
the uh uh the correlation of breeding
values that we get
uh from uh uh from those
models um this is being tested at scale
most successfully by the simmit maze
program at the moment who have scaled up
their late stage on Farm testing program
uh which is aimed at uh identifying
products for uh release uh and applied
it to uh uh generating um large numbers
of uh uh uh Farm as incomplete block uh
uh sit for uh model training for early
stage selection and this is a complex
thing to implement the simit team is
doing a really good job they have uh uh
you know a team devoted to this testing
both for late stage and ear early stage
uh uh
applications um that that it needs to be
done uh in collaboration with
organizations that get into Villages and
are doing Agricultural Development work
in villages you can't have a CGI
scientist or a a national program
scientist go to each of these sites and
plant and harvest collect data interview
the farmers you have to do this with
partners and they've got a very good
team for uh uh um setting up these these
Partnerships uh and they're they're um
uh constantly improving the uh uh the
way the uh the on Farm testing system
works uh data collection is about 85%
digitized uh they're getting a lot of uh
images of uh uh materials that have been
harvested that are that are going
into uh tra they're being converted into
traits and data return is pretty high uh
70 to
85% um so they're they're doing a good
job uh they're uh attempting to uh
gender disaggregate and characterize
Farmers uh in terms of uh uh different
aspects of a farmer typology that
they've been working on that uh the
primary axes are gender and uh uh and
wealth
um and uh this was first implemented in
uh 2022 2023 the uh results from uh uh
the on Farm trials for uh populations in
in simmit two main heterotic group are
uh are now available from from the first
year uh in heter audit group a uh there
were 449 selection candidates evaluated
in 180 trials so there there was some
and and uh four entries per trial and
there was some replication of selection
partial replication of selection
candidates uh in heterotic group uh B
there were
323 uh candidates 150 trials we've got
the uh heritabilities for and and the um
the trial types were
these on Farm trials and two types of on
station trial with the same same
candidates one was uh optimal management
at three locations one was uh management
under uh in an end depleted field at a
single location so
um the um uh heritabilities are on the
diagonal and interestingly heritability
on Farm using uh uh the
the the
grm um was essentially in in the same
ballpark as heritability on the research
station with this scale of trial the
scale of population so not you know our
the the hypothesis that selection on the
research station is much more accurate
was not borne out in this and the
genetic correlations between uh
performance on farm and under optimal or
low-end conditions were not high they
were uh Point uh four and essentially
zero for uh head group a 0 2 and and
essentially zero for for head Group B
this is strong evidence from a large
experiment that we need that that we
have a problem with the predictive power
of of uh uh research station
screening um we're still interested in
the question of uh you know the the
accuracy of uh different sparse testing
designs Christian Verner a quantitative
geneticist working for uh the uh um
accelerated breeding initiative of of
the genetic Innovation PL uh science
area the CG has been uh uh doing a a
simulation work on on sparse testing
models uh using Varian components that
are um sort of representative of the uh
uh cimit uh on Farm uh testing uh
uh system where uh you know scaled
relative to the uh uh the genetic
variance the genotype by year genotype
by location are five and seven times the
genetic variance uh respectively
three-way uh interaction of years
locations and genotypes about 10 times
the genetic variance and and the plot
residuals about 15 times and this uh
translates into a single plot
heritability of2 uh 02 this is about
about right you know this this this
Rings quite true uh to me but with by uh
using large families uh with the genomic
relationship Matrix you you achieve
effectively high levels of replication
uh for breeding value estimation and uh
um can you know reasonable levels of
accuracy so uh
Christian uh simulated using those
variance components and this is very
difficult to read and I I don't much
like this way of uh presenting these
results but I'll try and uh highlight a
couple of points he he he simulated a
population of 960 individuals the purple
bars are for complete replication at uh
one two four six or eight locations so
that's that's the accuracy that resulted
um these are different sparse testing
protocols with a total of
960 selection candidates same population
size but broken into two locations of
480 each four of 240 all the way down to
960 uh of
one um and
um yeah you know if you look at the mean
accuracy I'm asking him to convert this
into a table but uh uh if you look at
the mean accuracy
uh it doesn't you know once you get uh
uh four or five locations it doesn't
change very much and it's quite similar
to the accuracy you get with four
locations the the full set so even with
with highly dispersed sparse models you
get you get rather nice accuracies so uh
it looks like like we can use this uh
approach
to uh
evaluate um materials on Farm uh and get
and achieve a reasonable level of
accuracy um how is this going to impact
breeding in in in the developing world
I'm I'm pretty close to wrapping up here
I think the um it really requires a new
a new partnership model rapid cycle
recurrent selection is really hard to do
it's hard to do uh for uh individual uh
highly resourced skilled programs it's
much harder to do in a networked context
uh with in in a partnership mode uh in
um uh complex environments
internationally involving movement of
germplasm between
countries um the benefits in my opinion
of uh uh rapid cycle genomic selection
are great getting the the um breeding
cycle down to two or three years
sampling the target population of
environments better and reducing the uh
the or increasing the genetic
correlation between performance in the
screen uh and uh and in Farmers fields
we have the potential in Subs Africa to
double maybe triple rates of genetic
gain from from what we're currently
achieving these can only be delivered
quickly through intensive and long-term
partnership between National programs
and the CG supported by
uh um Advanced plant breeding research
institutions like this one like uh um uh
University of Queensland and a few
others that take a strong active uh uh
supporting interest in in uh in helping
uh National breeding programs um the
national programs the you know the the
power dynamic between National program
and and the CG programs Is Not Great
currently there's uh uh uh
the um CG programs uh tend to you know
the the the the basic critique Justified
more or less in different contexts is
that the CG programs use National
programs as a testing service
essentially in a technical mode there
are uh programs that that fits to a tea
there are programs that are highly
collaborative like the Faber Bean
program traditionally there are others
that that uh are pretty good as well but
but there is lots of Truth to that uh uh
that critique going forward to implement
rapid cycle genomic selection uh in a
network uh way um National Partners
really need to participate fully in
defining the markets that they serve the
products that they're going to uh uh uh
deliver and and really in in
um you know the the phenotyping
locations are at the national program
sites pheny typing needs to be uh LED
managed by by national Partners
supported by by Advanced Research
Institute um CG programs need to
contribute and transfer quantitative
genetics and pipeline optimization skill
and need to actively support highquality
phenotyping and the the other you know
real need for for uh CG coordination is
is germ physically managing the
populations because we need to you know
safely move germ plasm uh between
countries and most national programs
don't have a mandate or facilities to do
that uh at scale we also need for need
the the program to maintain Remnant seed
of every selection candidate for a cycle
or two so as uh candidates are
identified as having high breeding value
they can be shared among locations
remember with the sparse model we're not
sending every selection candidate to
every location we're not sending every
selection candidate necessarily to every
country um and uh National programs are
best positioned to extract commercial
products from populations under
Improvement by rapid cycle genomic
selection so you know I've been showing
this on and off for uh years and years
but but basically this is this is the
way it'll work the you know there'll be
a hub that advances The Source
population creates selection candidates
genotypes them and then pushes those
selection candidates out to Partners who
uh will do the
phenotyping um the the decision about
what to breed for what uh environments
What markets to serve needs to be
jointly made by these by this
partnership group but the division of
labor would efficiently look something
like this the the material is phenotyped
uh and data are sent back to train the
model uh to uh select the parents do the
next
cycle
so to wrap up sparse testing allows uh
the cycle to be shortened by limiting
the need for seed increase for
replication of candidates uh it also
permits much more extensive and deeper
sampling uh of the uh tpe that should
read during stage one uh when uh genomic
selection models are trained and most
selection pressure is applied both in
conventional
and genomic selection systems uh highly
dispersed farmers in complete blck
sparse designs permit on Farm genomic
selection model training and stage one
testing uh there's really no way to do
this without uh
um uh using a sparse design the accuracy
of uh dispersed um uh farmers in
complete block designs uh triot would be
one you know one example of that type of
design tends to be high even with as few
as three to four selection candidates
per f if you're really you know running
random sample of the tpe at each Farm uh
as you know according to to uh the
modeling and simulation results you can
go as low as as one um very small
numbers of of candidates per uh per Farm
permit uh resource poor and marginalized
Farmers to be included in the in the
training uh in the phenotyping for model
training this is really technically
tough it takes a lot of coordination uh
and will require well- supported
Regional breeding networks the idea that
an individual National program can
sustainably or uh or an individual CG
program can sustainably implement this
type of of breeding is uh in my mind uh
in my opinion
unrealistic uh and and I think the
division of labor will be that that
National partners and and CG or the
other uh supporting organization will
jointly identify the market to be served
jointly designed the
product CG or the Hub uh will manage
population advancement uh genotyping and
extraction of selection candidates um uh
National Partners will take the lead on
on running uh highquality uh sparse
trials and uh will extract and validate
commercial products because we need um
varieties to come out of this I've
talked a lot about selecting parents but
link this uh process to the extraction
of and and dissemination of commercial
varieties is is a critical part of the
process um those those those uh
candidate parents may be uh um potential
varieties they may need another cross to
to uh back fill uh gaps in the in the
product profile that that should be done
at the at the national level um I think
I'm out of time thank you for your
patience and uh happy to take any
questions questions from the
audience I've got a question about the
um Farm is block design um do the
farmers get to choose what they're
putting on their Farm or is it assigned
to them to make it more random I mean in
terms of of uh selection candidate yeah
yeah no they don't get to choose they
that's got to be assigned what the
farmer decides is how to manage that
plot right it's you know this works if
the uh researchers take their hands off
off the management um and that's a
that's a difficult thing for a lot of
researchers so real quick a followup so
then do you do any surveying beforehand
to kind of anticipate how they might
manage it or what type of conditions
they would have so that you can kind of
design your blocks that's a
a a good and important question so it's
critical to have as much information as
possible about the farmer and uh his or
her
circumstances um what type of management
they're using uh so um ideally the
research team
uh doesn't need to be there for planting
it doesn't need to be there for
harvesting because if if they do it's
almost a guarantee that planting and
harvesting will not be at at the optimal
time but uh the research team does need
to get out there and understand uh who's
uh in the sample you know who's
participating in the experiment uh and
get and to characterize those farmers
and their management absolutely and that
can be used to uh to group Farmers into
uh uh classes or groups that might you
know for example be using fertilizer
versus not using fertilizer and and
assign
assigning um uh reasonable weights to
both type you know up weighting or down
weighting Depend and and ideally
ensuring that you've got the right
sample uh at the start of the experiment
that's really hard to
do so are farmers paid somehow for the
use of their land because what I see is
there it's not really participatory in
any sense just using their L they're not
contributing to the assessment they're
doing well they are contributing to the
assessment they're being asked uh what
absolutely I thought you said that the
researchers from the Nars or whatever
would come around and do the assessments
no no no no sorry I that's not what I if
I if I said that that's not now the
researchers need to come around and talk
to the farmers yeah and you know
administer whatever instrument is being
used to to car to get information that
that'll allow uh farms and Farmers to be
characterized but um but are you paying
them something I'm just curious because
you're asking something oh yeah any on
Farm research this question arises it
and it it's a question people struggle
with my feeling is yeah they should be
paid uh the uh people who are doing this
research are I have never heard anyone
say that it's a good idea to pay Farmers
to do it um the uh but Farmers need to
benefit from being in these trials they
uh there are uh there are demands made
on people's time uh there are demands
made on people's land uh often the
benefit is we don't want for this
particular application we don't want to
give Farmers a bag of fertilizer that's
not you know um so what in in these
experiments what's been settled on is
providing seed of improved varieties
that people haven't got access to and
from my understanding is people are
reasonably ha happy to to do that also
uh it's quite important to have informed
participation so um you know I haven't
been in the field so I can't say the
extent to which this is uh adhered to
but um people uh need to and and I am
told that people are interested in
participating interested in uh you know
if they see that uh this type of
research has the potential to uh uh be
of some use to their Community there is
a often a positive inclination this can
I have a followup just because I'm
curious so um I think some of the aarda
trials they find that farmer
participation is high as long as they
can keep the Harvest oh it's critical to
keep the Harvest I just yeah okay
absolutely so they keep the Harvest and
I heard they were allowed to put
whatever varieties they happen to be
assign signed into their informal
community seed
banks yeah which they then continue to
breed and select on so I think that's
kind of an interesting dimension of
really getting a lot more diversity out
into the fields because that's what
they're going to be able we we've got
yeah we've got a um a I mean the primary
purpose of the onir trials is evaluation
right and both uh agronomic data are
collected and farmers are asked you know
in the triot style you know please rank
these why you know and why did you rank
them in this way what do you have to say
about these varities both both types of
data are collected but um the
uh Genetic Resource itself become
Farmers property to do with what they
want do they have Farmers
there's these these materials would be
International public goods
so they can do whatever they want they
can't claim a can't claim a an
intellectual property right over the
materials but I don't think we're going
to sign a material transfer agreement
with each farmer either but yes there um
I don't think there's any reason now in
maze these are hybrids right these are
test crosses so that that we think
no see that's the difference between you
and me S I have to think about maiz and
r
so uh yeah there but but there is no
uh you know the the bean exper version
of this experiment which I did not
discuss because I don't have any names
yet and they've had some hiccups
starting up um they uh
um Farmers uh you know I was quite
worried with beans actually that uh uh
they they get some real dogs you know
this is quite different than doing late
stage material late stage material you
know the the uh the stuff that goes on
Farm has been through a lot of screening
already it's not gonna completely fail
this stuff could completely fail and uh
the test cross is not so much because
they're it crossed on to a good tester
but um you know uh T was saying that uh
no there's a lot of people are taking
stuff out of the trials um I think that
I I I I I'm surprised you didn't also
document that this is a good way of
getting more diversity into farmer field
they can select on
it you know I you you and I have you
know some just different orientations
towards diversity I don't look at
African farming systems and see a lack
of
diversity um I look at too much
diversity in most context just depends
what they're dealing with in terms of
the stresses right yeah yeah but yeah
you know if people see something good
they should take it they can take it
yeah there's no reason not to but there
you know they're not gonna have many
data points on which to base that
decision either but it'll be a data
point that is extremely meaningful to
them yeah there's one question
people
online asking how have the Nars
responded to the model serving the
bottom the
complex
CG pyramid any concerns expressed about
depending on
C so
that's already happening I mean it's a
good and and you know the way you frame
that makes me think I need to somehow
flip that uh that slide
[Laughter]
over yeah
so that's part of a larger discussion
that's going on about uh how to
reorganize re
reframe Nars CG collaboration
um the there's you know there's nothing
about these networks that is going to
prevent National systems from continuing
where they do to do their own their own
run their own breeding pipelines this is
for uh is designed for um uh uh product
types that are grown over large regions
um and in which there is already a
collaborative breeding activity um but
this is part of an effort to
um
uh make these networks more
collaborative more Equitable um so but
but but that involves making sure that
that um National scientists are involved
in the governance and management of the
networks and that a larger share of
funding for the networks goes to the
National scientists the one thing that
we're we're we I've managed uh a number
of breeding networks in the CG National
scientists the main thing they want to
get is germplasm they and they want to
get germplasm
that's that's finished but variable and
they can select and finished in the
sense of fixed that's that's that's a
general rule um and these networks are
providing a lot of fixed germ plasant to
each site uh National scientists can
immediately take it use it visually
select and there are models that we're
looking at where they would get large
you know the the the amount that can be
sent out that's genotyped is is
constrained by budgets the amount that
can be sent out that's not genotyped is
a little less constrained by budgets so
um National Partners want to get germ
plasm they want to increase their
capacity in these areas so this is a you
know we're we're putting national uh
capacity building as an explicit
objective of these networks and the
resource share needs to change so
particularly in Subs not not in in um
South Asia uh you know iar budgets uh uh
dwarf those of uh the CG r large but in
subsaharan
Africa
um with you know I'm broad I'm painting
with a broad brush here but now many
national programs have research ations
they have staff they don't have
operating budgets you know uh and so I
think for um for Africa to uh uh speed
up climate change adaptation make it
more effective funders are going to have
to put those operating budgets into the
breeding pipelines linked into this type
of network but much more directly sorry
ahead yeah I was uh wondering do you
have an estimate so first off I thought
it was really important to see that the
on Farm had zero correlation with low
input simulation I'm hoping that's not
uh I'm hoping that's not the case going
forward but it's very interesting yeah
I'm very concerned that could be real
and that I've got I've seen some other
things from other types of experiment
that indicate that that might not be
zero no that that might not be
inaccurate yeah but so but you know at a
certain level so how much is it costing
for on research station per entry versus
on Farm per entry you know talking all
the way I could see a 20-fold
differential between a
$10 uh entry on on research station and
you know $200 or $300 per
entry you know distributed system
distributed system and at a certain
point it's better just run more research
stations yeah yeah across enough
geographies than it is to do on Farm
because there's too much contact costs
working with all the farmers well that
and that's what groups like minara and
Jill in the in the simmit program are
boiling out right so yeah if it's the CG
scientists who are doing the contact
it's impossible right but if it's
National Partners if it's local NOS if
it's Farmers
groups uh it it becomes quite cost
effective the
um if you look at the the cost structure
of a CG our breeding
program roughly 80% of the costs are and
this would be for a USDA program too I
would imagine roughly 80% of the costs
are research
station uh and um paying permanent staff
International staff 20% of the costs are
so are variable costs associated with
generating genotyping and phenotyping
selection candidates so moving some of
that on Farm is isn't going to massively
affect the cost structure of these
breeding networks you sure does that
cost Shi to the
nurse oh you have to pay for this
yeah no I mean uh yeah I
mean it if you are getting extension
workers from a national system to do
this then yeah you're using their time
it's an opportunity cost for their time
it might be an upgrade in the
productivity of their time relative to
what they were doing um you would have
to find the money to get them to the
farm get them back pay the pdans that
you know that is often $150 to $200 per
site but if you want to you know put the
full cost of a plot at a CGI reseearch
station onto that that plot you got to
put the DG's salary onto the plot also
right it's not $10 per
plot any more questions olly thanks Gary
I just there's a bit of a tension with
the marginalized farmers and
representatives
social because you know different
approaches you could either over sample
farmers who may have been historically
marginalized and say I want to test
there because if you kind of
Representative s of
social what you're
thinking indicators you could end up
with
that
represent does that make sense whereas
if you say women haven't been a part of
system we want over
represent the fs that so I'm just
wondering like in terms of that
representativeness versus rectifying
hisorical
choices around who's being represented
in
these that's kind of a short service I'm
just wondering how
that my my gut feeling is
that oh yeah sorry um if I understood
the question properly uh Holly was
saying that there may be an argument for
um over representing groups in the
training population who have been
traditionally
excluded uh and or or
overlooked um I I you know I don't know
about over representation what um I
think it's it it's important to air on
the side of
inclusion uh so um typically these types
of experiment don't hit their targets I
think for including uh marginalized
Farmers female Farmers um so yeah I you
know I would I would air on that side I
don't think it's going to turn out this
is not going to be an exact science and
I think what what we're seeing is that
the
correlations in perform in performance
between the the categories tend to be
positive and often quite high but also
these Co these variances covariances are
measured at very low Precision because
as you Dice this sample up the you know
the sample size for women in a lower
wealth category starts to get very small
men in a lower wealth category starts so
this and this is something we've seen
right we we started to see extremely
high or low gentic correlations in
places we didn't it didn't make sense
and it turned out that the the the um
the variance
estimates were were wonky because of
small samples so so uh I think you know
I think as we do this we're going to see
we need this needs to be scaled up even
more than than it has
been okay folks that was super cool
thank
you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu